Yeah,
easily,
for example,
Jews,
the Jewish Egyptians were very,
very accepted.
The very prominent,
and I will give you some quick examples,
are the assistant of our Greek leader of
1990 revolution,
Sadza who was our group leader who made
the revolution against the British
occupation.
His assistant was Jewish,
Egyptian,
uh,
some of the founders of the Egyptian
economies war,
uh,
and that was our way to fight back
against the,
the English occupation to have our own
university and our own economy and our
own banks and the were Jewish families.
You see,
it was even some of the,
of the very,
very famous movie stars in Egypt.
The forties were Jews you see at the,
it was not even accepted to identify
Egyptians according to the religion that
was totally impolite to say,
or even to refeed that somebody ensure
Christian,
you'll see a,
there were options like any other
Egyptians who happened to be just like
the Egyptians who happen to be
Christians or Muslims.
So we had our very,
very great positive experience about
Jews with Jews.
And uh,
the problem with us was not.
The problem was was Israel,
you see,
and it is very dangerous to confuse the
two concepts.
I would say that some people in Israel
feel very comfortable to confuse,
to confuse,
to mix up the two,
uh,
concepts in the,
in the sense that if you are critical
against some Israeli policies,
so accordingly you are against Jews.
And this is terribly wrong,
terribly wrong.
You see,
because I am,
I believe that the,
I am very critical against the Saudi
regime and I believe it's a terrible
regime,
but this does not mean that I'm against
all Arabs or Muslims.
So I think that we never had a,
we never had really a problem or a
discrimination against Jews in the hole.